hallo mein name ist luca und wir stellen
heute zusammen einen diamanten dieses
spiel heißt die dinge wie diamond und
wir müssen alles klar das spiel ist
genau so aufgebaut wie der ausbruch aus
dem gefängnis video was ich mal gemacht
habe was ich euch hier verlinkt da könnt
ihr euch das anschauen gleich oder nach
oder keine ahnung wir haben immer so ein
paar auswahlmöglichkeiten sind dieser
kleine tüten und hier klicken einfach
mal auf play und die story geht los okay
das ist das gebäude das wir einbrechen
müsse und werde entweder basteln oder
sneak in wir nehmen natürlich passt denn
ok ok ist das habe ich mir wieder
richtig gut gelöst gerade wir machen
kick und stark luca machen wir jetzt mal
also wir haben die weg aus dem hut gar
nicht glauben ich bin spieler nicht vom
alter bieten
basket schnell schnell kollege packen
scharein also nicht bei dieser dunklen
lief also wie wird das ist so ein
dummkopf einfach nur ok diesmal springen
wir mal übernimmt also das ist auf jeden
das einsame spitze machen wieder genau
das gleiche wie rahmen die leute erst
weg so jetzt sind wir schon beim ersten
vorbei an ihm kommen wir jetzt daran
vorbei weil ich glaube der ist ein
scheiß tags darauf nehmen ich bin
schlecht denn im spiel
ob wir wieder das cable packen das schön
dran raten mit dem diamanten weg jetzt
sind wir wieder auf der vollen straßen
werden verfolgt von der polizei
unternehmen diesmal brannten
und jetzt sind wir wieder auf der straße
wir nehmen jetzt schön den stein als
auswahlmöglichkeit 4 für den stein
schnell meisten stein nach hinten und
jetzt waren wir alles klar ein
helikopter okay
meistens klappt das alles klappt die
bubble ist die richtige entscheidung
gewesen alles sei als das da ist weiter
geht der helikopter kann ich durch den
tunnel durch wir sind hier in sonne
drinnen geht und außen ton raus und o
demnach schaut ich bin gestrandet mit
dem diamanten hier so da wir das jetzt
auf dem aggressiven weg geschafft haben
würde ich jetzt mal sagen dass wir jetzt
mal den leisen weg nehmen und zwar jetzt
liegen uns rein okay wir haben wieder
verschiedene auswahlmöglichkeiten
erstmal das anti gravity cap dingsbums
das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus wir
sind auf dem weg nach oben und können
erst dann gibt immer diese ampel hoppers
ich meine damen müssen sie eigentlich
klar gehe nicht einfach
dieser vollidiot was dies mit dem dann
nehmen jetzt mal den teleporter das ist
okay vdm das sieht nicht gesund aus okay
wir sind oben angekommen
wir nehmen den wir nehmen den sport also
dem kopf mir gerade beim gegen ins
gesicht schlagen voll gegen den zahn
geschlagen hast du toll hier kommen dann
nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal den penny
so dumm wie es klingt und neueste sollte
einfach geglaubt ok entweder drop wire
oder portugal
was ist ca das dümmste was man nehmen
würde ich glaube wir lassen uns einfach
mal fallen und jetzt
das dümmste ist nicht immer das beste
freunde kommen jetzt machst du da noch
ein portal genau alles klar wir haben in
den nandi den diamanten jetzt mit einem
laser katar kommen nimmt den laser katar
du vollidiot ok dem wir haben den
diamanten kommen wir nehmen den käse
ich kann nicht lesen
die kanone alter das ist so du bist doch
auch jetzt setzt sich da rein schnell
als das ist doch so ein dummkopf ich den
a dieses spiel okay alles klar stehen
wir sind auf dem kissen gehen jetzt raus
nehmen uns die riffe kommt einfach den
diamanten schutz einfach den diamanten
auf den typen runter ja ok mit diamanten
nehme mit schnell
meine freunde haben es geschafft auf
beiden wegen ich hoffe euch hat das
video gefallen wenn es das getan hat
würde ich mich vorbereiten und sonst
sehen wir uns im nächsten video wieder
wenn irgendwelche von dummen
behindertenspiele kennen schreibt die
mir die in die kommentare
in der tat